[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALICIA SALMERON: My
name is Alicia Salmeron,
and I lead strategic
partnerships
at Google for Education.
Today, you're going to hear from
students and researchers who
are using GCP to discover
black holes in the universe,
new painkillers that could help
us address the opioid crisis,
as well as communication devices
that can enable the deaf.
Joining me today are Alon and
Tomer from Columbia University,
Vaikunth from Stanford SLAC,
and Nil from the University
of Southern California.
You'll hear their
stories in just a moment.
This quote from Ryan
Abernathey, a climate researcher
at Columbia University,
really says it all for me.
The amount of data in academic
as well as scientific research
is exploding.
And researchers
really have no option
but to look to the cloud.
But what the cloud is
enabling them to do
is to make discoveries faster.
Ryan used GCP in his lab.
And he made note that
he's able to ask more
questions, different questions.
Take a moment to
read that last line.
Really hits home, doesn't it?
We have two programs that enable
students and researchers to get
started on GCP at no cost.
The first is the Education
Faculty Grants Program.
This program
provides free credits
to faculty who want to
use GCP in their courses
with their students.
Courses from computer
science to engineering
as well as business operations
and anything involving
data science are already
leveraging GCP credits.
Our second program is the
GCP Research Credits Program.
Researchers can apply
for free credits,
and they can use
this in their lab
for any type of evaluation,
experimentation, or testing.
We have researchers
sequencing genomes, learning
and researching about
life forms in galaxies
far away as well as
far deep underneath--
not underneath the ocean floor,
but near the ocean floor.
So with that, I would
love to introduce
our first presentation
from Tomer and Alon
at Columbia University.
TOMER AHARONI: Imagine not being
able to call your loved ones.
Imagine not being able to
call 911 during an emergency.
Imagine someone was listening
to every single phone
call you made.
You don't have to imagine.
37.5 million adults in
the US report suffering
from some sort of hearing loss.
That's 15% of the US population.
What do these people do?
How do they place phone calls?
Well, today, people with
hearing disabilities
have to use a
captioning service.
What that means is, if I
want to call a friend who's
hard of hearing, I'm
being transferred
to a man in the middle.
That's an actual
human being listening
to everything I say, type it,
and send it to a special device
that the other side must own.
Think about it for a second.
It can take almost a
minute from the moment
I say something to the time
the other side hears it.
This is crazy.
Let's don't even
talk about privacy.
Someone is listening
to everything I say.
The year is 2019.
We have self-driving cars.
We created rockets that
can go out to space
and land back on Earth.
And still, if you
have trouble hearing,
if you're hard of
speaking, there's
no way for you to make
a decent phone call.
We want to change that.
That's why we created Nagish.
Nagish stands for
"accessible" in Hebrew.
And our mission is to make
phone calls more accessible.
How we do that?
To explain, I'd like to
call my partner, Alon Ezer,
to the stage.
ALON EZER: All right.
So I want to go back to
the captioning service
Tomer just mentioned and
tell you a short story that
happened to me.
So I wanted to contact Jack from
the New York Deaf Association
to talk about
collaboration, offer him
beta testing for free,
and just hear his opinion.
But I was connected to
a captioning service.
And that was a little
bit strange for me,
because that was the first
time I really encountered that.
And by the end of
the conversation,
it even became more awkward.
I was telling Jack
about this new service
that Tomer just introduced
that will take away
the work from the
captioning service,
and I had to do it through
the captioning service.
So it didn't feel right.
And it felt like
there's no privacy.
And I can't even imagine how
Jack feels every single day.
So now that's why
we created Nagish.
We want to bring privacy
and independence back
to phone calls, so Jack can be
just on the go, use his phone
whenever he wants.
So how would that conversation
look like today using Nagish?
Instead of captioning
service and a man
in the middle that
transcribes everything
I say back and forth, and
it's slow, tedious process,
we just use Google
Speech-to-Text API,
which basically takes
my voice, my sound,
and converts it into text.
That text we send to
Jack's mobile phone,
and now he can just
read what I said.
Simple enough.
Now, if Jack wants
to respond back,
he can use Google Hangouts,
Facebook Messenger, WhatsApp,
Telegram, and many
more that we're
planning to support
in the future,
and just respond, type
back, send a message.
When he sends the message,
we convert it back to speech,
to voice, and we
send it to my phone,
and I hear exactly
what Jack typed.
And now we're both happy again.
And we have a normal phone
call, like any other person
in the world.
And simple as that.
If this is cool,
the coolest part
is we were able to build
it in less than 12 hours.
We started in a
coding competition
in our school,
Columbia University,
and with Google
products, we were
to have a working demo
by the end of the day.
And to show you how Nagish
works, here's a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE RINGING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
- Hey.
Where are you?
I just got here.
- Oh, OK.
I'll be there in a second.
- Perfect.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
TOMER AHARONI: Thank you.
So as you can see, we're
pretty excited by this.
But the question that we must
ask is, where can we go next?
ALON EZER: So we're currently
working with beta testers
to test our service, improve
it, and make it really
something that they can
use every single day.
Besides that, we
have conference calls
that we want to use Nagish
in a more professional way,
so they can use it
while they work.
TOMER AHARONI: Yeah,
also, we wanted
to create personalized voices.
So for instance, adults won't
have the same voice as child.
We feel like that each person
should have their unique voice,
even if they can't speak.
If you want to hear
more about Nagish
and read about what we're
doing, check out our website
at TalkNagish.co,
where you'd also
find a live transcript
of this keynote that
was generated using the
same technology that
empowers Nagish.
ALON EZER: And if you would
like to see a live demo,
please find us that the
Google for Education
booth right after this talk.
And we're going to be there
until the end of the day.
Hope to see you.
And now Vaikunth is coming
to speak about space.
TOMER AHARONI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VAIKUNTH THUKRAL: Thanks, guys.
Before I begin, I
just have a question.
Did any of you get a chance to
check out the latest news today
about the first ever
photo of a black hole?
It just came out
this morning, right?
[APPLAUSE]
Right.
So, yeah, I'm going to be
talking about similar things
here.
Hopefully, that
gets you excited.
So, hey, everyone.
My name is Vaikunth,
and I'm a researcher
at Stanford at
SLAC National Lab,
just down the road
from here, and I'd
like to talk to you about
unlocking a vast trove of data
to study the secrets of
the universe, cool things
like dark matter
and dark energy.
96%.
This might surprise
you, but we don't
know 96% of what's out
there in the universe.
Everything you see in that
photo, tens of thousands
of galaxies, our own galaxy, our
tables, our chairs, you and me,
every single thing
only comprises 4%
of the matter in the universe.
That's a lot.
We don't know what's out there.
96% is what we need to find out.
So to unlock the
secrets of that 96%,
we're going to need
a lot of information.
The universe, just by
virtue of existing,
provides us with this
information all around us.
We need a way to
collect that information
and then study it to be able
to study what's going on.
This is where I come in.
My job as a researcher
is to create
a system that is able to
collect all this information
and provide a platform for
astrophysicists and astronomers
and any scientist who's
interested to study the data
and look into the
secrets of the universe.
And with Google, we've also been
able to create a platform that
helps us do that.
For the data management
system, we're
going to need a telescope
to power the images that
give us all that data.
This is where LSST comes in.
It's called the Large
Synoptic Survey Telescope.
This telescope will provide
the deepest, widest image
of the universe to date.
It's going to be the world's
biggest camera-based telescope.
Every single picture
that you see online,
even the one that
came out today, it
comes from collaborating with
a bunch of other telescopes,
taking lots and lots of
exposures, tons of analysis
done on them, lots
of algorithms,
that eventually gives you a
nice, pretty picture that you
can look at.
Now, how do you do that
for hundreds or thousands,
and in the end,
millions of pictures?
We're going to need a
really huge machine.
This is where LSST comes in.
It's a project being
built in Chile right now.
And the next video
will show you a sense
of scale of what this
telescope is about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
So, yeah, that should give you
an idea of what's going on.
It takes hundreds of people,
thousands of scientists
to make this thing.
And it's been envisioned
over 10 years ago.
It finally got funding
in, like, 2010.
And it's been under
construction since.
It's going to be in
production about 2021, '22,
and it'll provide us
with all these images
that we can look at.
So how big is this
telescope exactly?
The camera behind this
telescope is 3,200 megapixels.
Think of your cell phone.
The best ones are usually
10 to 12 megapixels,
and those take
pretty nice photos.
Every single exposure with this
telescope is 3,200 megapixels.
That's about the size of
40 full moons, one image.
It takes one of these
images every 15 seconds,
and it's going to do that over
10 years from 2021 to 2030-ish.
That ends up being 15
terabytes of data per night,
and in the end, 37 billion stars
and galaxies for us to look at.
It's a lot of information
in that database in the end.
So with all these hundreds
of scientists, thousands
of people that are
interested in this data, that
want to discover new things
from this survey of the sky,
we're going to need a data
management platform that can
easily enable them to do that.
So currently, LSST
is based in Chile,
and collaborating with
scientists in the US.
Imagine there's a
scientist in Australia
who's also interested in
studying dark matter and dark
energy via their own telescope
or their own collaboration,
and they've never had anything
to do with LSST before.
They have information
about weak lensing,
for example, which
is one way to study
dark matter and dark energy.
One of the ways that scientists
make progress on measurements
and equations is to combine
measurements and iterate
on current accepted values.
They can bring their own
data, spin up everything
that we've provided in Google
Cloud with our data management
system, with our services, with
our data compared against what
they have, at their
own cost, which
enables them to combine into a
new measurement for dark matter
and dark energy.
Cost is, of course, a part
of any equation on campus,
because that's
really important when
it comes to researchers,
because we always
rely on government funding.
This brings us to
the proof of concept
that LSST worked
with with Google.
This was practically an exercise
in running our data management
system that has been planned for
the operation of the telescope
and running it in the cloud.
This means we took
our database system,
our associated services,
things that we containerized
and Kubernetesized, made it
easily available and deployable
by others, and not just
experts, and run them on GCP.
And the way we
compared performance
was by benchmarking
things that we had already
done on our own data centers,
and with things called KPMs
or key performance metrics.
This is an ongoing study.
I cannot really talk too
much about the numbers.
But in certain cases,
in certain classes
of queries that
scientists like to run,
we saw improvements of
up to 10x in the times
that it takes to get
results out of queries.
One of the things that
I do want to mention
throughout our proof of concept
is that the Google Professional
Services people were
really helpful and hands-on
in helping us bring our
entire data management
system onto the cloud, which
really made things easy.
And in the end, that
is our objective,
to create a system that's
easy, flexible to use,
and other scientists
and non-experts
should be able to use as well.
So for other
researchers thinking
about getting on
the cloud, I want
to talk about a
special point, which
is every researcher,
every type of research,
not just astronomy, not
just biology, and not just--
literally everything has
special requirements,
because there's very
specific ways to do things.
And it's really bespoke
to the type of analysis
that you're doing.
It's sometimes
difficult to think
that it would be possible to
do that somewhere else, and not
just your own
system, your own data
center, your own specialized
system that you've created.
But I wanted to talk
about how we were
able to do that still at GCP.
For example, one of the things
that we've done in our system
is something called
shared scans.
And what that does
is, when you submit
a query that looks at
the entire data, which
is a very frequent thing
that scientists like to do,
any further query that comes
into the system tags along,
and it adds no further
overhead to the system.
And that way we can
look at the entire data
sets for one query
or 100 queries,
and it should work
exactly the same.
Another specific thing that
astronomers need for LSST
is something called
spherical geometry.
Think about Google
Maps for a second.
When you kind of scroll out,
you see that the coordinates
are in a sphere, right?
You zoom out, and you look at
distances between two points,
it's actually a curve.
In the same way,
when we're taking
photos of the night sky
and all these images,
if you think about it, we're
in the center of that globe.
So we need an accurate
way to look for objects,
around other objects, distances
between things accurately
with spherical geometry in
mind, so we can calculate
those things accurately.
Things like that were
also adaptable in things
like BigQuery,
where we could make
special UDFs and other
functions to be able to do
that in the way that we need.
So I can go on and on about
all the specific things
that we did and tried.
But if you're interested more
about the LSST data management
team, you can find
out more in that link.
And ultimately,
what I want to say
is that our objective is to
build a system that is really
easy to use, flexible
for other scientists,
for other non-experts,
and really
enables science output out
of this experiment for as
many papers as possible, and
have the scientists concentrate
more on delivering
science results
rather than worrying about
the underlying technology,
because after all, we still
have 96% of the universe left
to understand.
With that, I will hand over
to the next speaker, Nil,
who would like to talk
about the opioid crisis.
[APPLAUSE]
NILKANTH PATEL:
Thank you, Vaikunth.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Nilkanth
Patel, and I am
a graduate student
at the University
of Southern California.
And today I'm going to
share a story about fight
against the opioid epidemic
in the Google Cloud.
What we are trying to do here
is to design better drug, better
painkillers faster.
What takes more than a
year in a normal research
lab takes less than a
day on Google Cloud.
Opioid epidemic.
So the US is currently facing
a true national emergency
as opioid epidemic.
And more than 130
people every day,
or close to 50,000
people every year,
die because of opioid epidemic.
To put this in
perspective, this number
is even higher than people
dying from car accidents.
In fact, in the next 10
minutes, while I do this talk,
one person will die because
of opioids in the US.
So let's look at
where this started.
The use of opioids dates
back to even centuries.
And its social and
cultural impacts
can still be found in
early civilizations,
including Romans
and the Egyptians.
Back then, it was all derived
from natural products.
It was derived from poppies.
But now, as you can see here,
it has gone totally synthetic.
It has become much more powerful
and much more addictive.
Back then, it had
impacted human history,
and wars were fought
because of opioids.
One such example is
the first Opium War,
which was fought between
British-backed East India
Company and the Chinese kingdom.
Back then, we only had morphine,
which is derived from poppy.
But with even more
powerful synthetic opioids,
nowadays, the challenges
become even more grave.
And take a look at
the map of the US
and see how it's impacting the
US at every level of income,
culture, and race.
Take a moment and find
the region you belong to
and see how severely
it's impacted
by the opioid epidemic.
So let me switch
gears and see how
this works in terms of biology.
So in layman's
term, you can think
of these opioid
drugs as keys, keys
which binds to a set of
proteins in our brain
called the opioid receptors.
So human body is
made up of cells.
And cells have cell
walls engulfing them.
And the cell membranes
have these gatekeepers
or these opioid receptors
sitting across the membrane.
And when these keys
or extra molecules
bind to these
receptors, either they
activate them or
they block them.
And when it comes to pain
management, in the brain,
there are two major pathways.
One pathway leads
to pain relief,
which is the desired effect.
But activating
another pathway leads
to undesired side effects,
such as respiratory depression
and tolerance.
So whether drug will activate
one pathway or another
or it will block
the receptor, it
depends on the structure
of these keys or the drugs
and how they interact
with these receptors.
So you don't really have
a choice as to whether you
want to get addicted or not.
It's not in our hands.
It's up to these
receptors and how
they function in our brains.
So here is a short
visualization.
It's actually a molecular
dynamic simulation
showing an opioid drug
binding to an opioid receptor.
So in purple, this drug
and the blue spirals
is opioid receptor.
So an answer to fight this
challenge of opioid epidemic
is redesign and
find better keys,
keys that bind these receptors.
And our lab has been
working on these targets
since more than a decade.
So here is what we are
going to do to fight this.
We and our colleagues have
solved the atomic-level 3D
structures of these
receptors or these locks.
And once you know
how these locks work,
then you can design
and screen better keys.
So once we have the description
or two-dimensional description
of these receptors,
then we throw
in bunch of keys or
small druglike molecules,
and find those ones
which can interact
with these keys, these locks,
and show desired effect.
So here is where the
action happens, actually.
So in this video, it
may look like a bunch
of things happening.
What it's actually showing is
we are screening different keys.
And this process is called
virtual [INAUDIBLE] screening.
In this process, we
evaluate a single drug
molecule in different
blocking poses,
and we calculate different
chemical interactions for them.
And through this
process, there are
thousands of
different orientations
which are evaluated
for every single drug.
And this process happens
for hundreds of millions
of druglike compounds.
So you might be wondering,
why is this important?
So by this process, we
can find most promising
druglike candidates, and then
we can select them and test them
actually in the lab.
And here the story gets
even more interesting.
In the past two
years, the size of
these small druglike molecule
libraries have grown rapidly.
What used to be in tens of
millions a few years ago is now
have grown to more
than a billion in size.
So while this presents
a great challenge
in terms of size of the
problem and compatibility,
this presents a
unique opportunity
in terms of exploring the
ever-expanding chemical
space to have more options
to find better druglike
chemicals from.
So in a nutshell,
what's worked for
us is the speed at which we can
do computations on the cloud.
So let me give you
a simple comparison.
What we have here in
our lab is on the left--
it's usually 500 processors--
and what we have on the cloud.
So you are using almost
200,000 processors in parallel
at a given point in time.
And what used to
take more than a
year to screen at such a scale
now takes less than a day
or two on the cloud.
So far in this story, which
began almost a year ago,
with the help of National
Institute of Health
and its pilot program
on cloud computing,
and also with the
help from NIDA,
National Institute
of Drug Abuse,
and Google Research
Credit Programs,
we screened almost
half a billion
of such druglike compounds.
And we selected 120 compounds
and tested them in the lab.
And indeed we found some of
the promising compounds, which
have shown desired
signaling profiles.
So we'll continue our fight
against the opioid epidemic
in the cloud in the hope
of saving millions of lives
and changing the faces
of the addiction.
With that, I'd like
to thank you all.
And special thanks to my mentor,
Professor Vsevolod Katritch,
and Sarosh and Edward from
Google, and Jim from Onix.
ALICIA SALMERON:
Tomer and Alon, I
thought it was
fantastic that you
were able to get going
with a prototype in one
day at a campus hackathon.
What would the
advice be that you
would give to other
students that are
looking to get started on GCP?
TOMER AHARONI: So when
I got started with GCP,
I didn't have much
programming experience.
I took a few classes,
but not more than that.
And what I would say is
just go and try stuff.
I failed my first hackathon.
And we won the second
one and I think every one
that we went to since then.
So just keep trying.
Do crazy stuff.
Do easy stuff, then go
to stuff that are harder,
and keep trying.
The GCP console makes it really
easy to achieve great stuff.
ALON EZER: I think Tomer
covered most of it.
Like he said, begin
from easy things.
Like, Google Translate
API is very simple to use,
and you can have a
result in a minute,
and it's very satisfying.
So maybe try that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]